all right what's going on guys this is
rob and welcome back to high train the
show where we get hyped about the things
that we've seen and stuff that's
happening and
in this video we're talking about the
most recent episode of falcon in the
winter soldier now episode number four
was amazing right it was a really really
really good episode and here's the thing
right i was against the idea that sharon
carter's the power broker i know a lot
of you guys support that and i'm kind of
coming around to it because my thought
was
if sharon if sharon carter really was or
if the power broker was not sharon
carter we would know by now they would
have introduced the power broker by now
because this is a six episode series i'm
pretty sure
and we're four episodes in so either
they're gonna show the power broker in
episode number five
or it's gonna be sharon carter right and
i feel like at this point with the
reveal like with with
things progressing as they have i think
the reveal will be that it's sharon
carter i still like the idea
that thunderbolt ross is the one pulling
the strings but it'd be kind of
intriguing right because sharon carter
could have it could have been one of
these things where like she was she felt
betrayed by the government right she was
like disavowed from shield and kind of
given the boot and for whatever manner
and by whatever matter whatever it means
she set up shop in madrid and is
basically
a former hero turned villain right we've
seen that happen all the time that was a
story of taskmaster in marvel comics
right the villain from black widow
taskmaster was a shield agent who
eventually turned to becoming a
mercenary and a villain it's not
uncommon to see that kind of thing
happen
in marvel comics in any event the
episode itself man it was it was good it
was it was great world building
um i think it's kind of intriguing
because i still stand by the idea that
baron zima wants to basically get rid of
all the superheroes right because he
killed wilford nagel and they destroyed
the super soldier serum right so like
we've basically seen him kind of going
on this
sort of storyline based quest for
himself to get rid of any of the
superhero elements that he possibly can
which brings us into the theory portion
of the show because episode number four
was good and i think we can all pretty
much agree on that
let's start with john walker right john
walker was amazing in this whole thing
and i guess it was only really a matter
of time i like the fact that they're
using ptsd that's basically what he kind
of had in the comics a little bit he was
just a little more a little a little too
extreme
but having ptsd is a highly relevant
thing because it's something that's
that's
a lot of people who are former soldiers
struggle with consistently and so it's
kind of cool to see them bring that to
the forefront and to have basically
battle star die
as the the kind of catalyst that sends
them over the edge after having taken
the super soldier
serum the funny thing about this is that
in in marvel comics there's not really a
precedent
for that with a super soldier serum
basically sending people over the edge
marvel kind of teeters around the notion
of having this element where like it
enhances
the existing properties of an individual
the whole concept of what you see
a person taking the super soldier serum
and then enhancing their personal
attributes that's a marvel cinematic
universe thing as far as i'm aware that
was established in captain america one
right so a person who's kind and
generous like steve rogers was
they would enhance those attributes
whereas a person who was dark and
sinister like the red skull was would
enhance those attributes and so because
of that it makes perfect sense what
they're doing with john walker this idea
that his ptsd and all that kind of stuff
is basically just pushed to greater
heights by virtue of him taking the
super soldier serum and then
experiencing the loss of a of a teammate
once again right and so i love what
they're going with that the big question
is how does it end for john walker okay
so i think for john walker goes one of
two ways
either john walker dies or john walker
joins the thunderbolts i think it only
goes it goes one of those two ways i
think that john walker's a character
where you can't really bring him back
the marvel cinematic universe might be
going the route where like they don't
want to communicate the message
those with ptsd who are from the
military the only way to save them is to
kill them like it might be that they
don't want to communicate that message
so the third option here is that he goes
back to therapy right where he's talking
to the chick that bucky barnes was
talking to at the beginning of the show
which he was already doing they just
kind of send him back right he just sort
of reworks on all that kind of stuff and
and improves himself and goes back to
being what i guess you would define as a
as a normal person that's not really
struggling with ptsd in that way i guess
that's the third option
but given the nature of the mcu in the
fact that john walker's kind of being
built up to be a villain the mcu
historically
kills their villains and so if that's
the case and john walker is going to be
a true villain as opposed to an
anti-hero because they haven't really
given us much to identify with right
it'd be different if like bucky barnes
went rogue again right and was like
doing some villainous stuff again then
we would be rooting for him we want him
to come back and just be like yeah man
you know bucky is cool man you got this
you know just just make amends and
everything will be forgiven with john
walker it's just like from the word go
we hated that guy and they made us hate
that guy because he's like the fake
captain america like nobody looked at
john walker and is like that's a guy i
can get behind thank you kevin feige and
the mcu for giving us a new captain
america nobody's saying that
and so it looks like he's being built up
as a villain and if he is they're going
to kill him off
if not he's going to join the
thunderbolts and i'll talk about why
that matters here in a second
but the next thing is is carly
morgenthau right so carly morgenthau
she is a character that's had a lot of
development and a lot of buildup but i
think that the statement that's being
offered by baron zemo in saying that
she's basically lost and she can't be
saved
you can't interpret that as being just
an aspect of baron zemo being
exceedingly cynical towards those who
have power just inherently
you know untrustworthy of them but i
think what's real and
and what's really tangible there is that
he looks at it as though she really is
just a person who cannot be redeemed and
i would say that if she didn't witness
john walker
killing her teammate right like beating
him to death with the shield
then like there'd be a chance to bring
her back and i think it's one of those
things where with the encounter she had
with falcon he almost brought her back
and then as soon as john walker went
running in there and screwed everything
up she went she fell back over the edge
and there's no bringing her back and so
i would say that much like with john
walker that she'll end up either dying
or joining the thunderbolts i think it's
more
likely she'll join the thunderbolts for
for a character like her as for sam
wilson and for uh for
for bucky barnes they're gonna go back
and it's gonna be business as usual
right it's just gonna you know
the day's gonna be saved and that's you
know it's like cool you guys are able to
kind of do your thing and they're gonna
be friends
i think that that sam wilson is gonna
become the new captain america and i
think that bucky barnes is gonna become
like he'll just be the winner soldier
i think he's gonna become new falcon
he's just gonna be the new winner like
the the winter soldier and they're just
gonna be teammates as opposed to like a
superhero and a sidekick i think it'll
be more equitable
in terms of uh of how they work together
and how all that stuff functions
but uh but by and large i think that the
the day is just gonna be saved right you
know everything's gonna be okay for them
which
leaves us only a couple of different
characters right the first is sharon
carter and the second is baron zemo so
let's talk about sharon carter first
right kind of cycling back around at the
beginning of the video
um assuming that you guys are right and
she really is the power broker she's not
going anywhere right if she really is
the power broker they're gonna keep her
because of the fact that she has the
ability to synthesize the super soldier
serum an important thing to understand
here in in marvel assuming that they can
somehow duplicate the work of wilford
nagel which i don't know if they can
because they destroyed his lab but one
of the things about marvel comics when
it comes to the super soldier serum and
i might make a video explaining this
over at comics explained is that in the
comic books
no one's ever successfully duplicated
the serum of steve rogers the only time
they ever even really came
close to that was with the grand
designer when in 1953 when he went to
what was supposed to be the lab of
abraham erskine and
discovered like leftover paperwork from
when abraham erskine was in germany
before he was taken by nick fury in the
howling commandos and brought to the
states to work on project rebirth aka
the captain america project that
one-off right there is the only time
that you ever see anybody get close
beyond that it's just a series of
attempts to duplicate the super soldier
serum right so if you look at the main
marvel universe it's wildly
complex and unnecessary the marvel
cinematic universe is largely based on
marvel comics ultimate universe line
that was launched in 2000 and so when
you look at that and you look at the
super soldier serum in that line of
comics
basically all the different spider-man
clones are based on the super soldier
project the idea of uh james howlett
becoming wolverine is a byproduct of the
super soldier project right there's all
kinds of different things like the
ultimate development of what became the
green goblin was rooted in creating a
new super soldier serum right everything
goes back to trying to create
new super soldiers and so if marvel
wants to do that if the marvel cinematic
universe wants to almost kind of turn
this space race so to speak for a new
super soldier serum or a workable super
soldier serum into the new plot going
forward in the marvel cinematic universe
especially if they want to use it as a
means to explain where like mutants come
from or something like that then you're
not going to see the power broker go
anywhere either that or the power broker
is going to die and then somebody else
is going to pick up the slack
the reality is that again again you know
i think that the power broker has kind
of been built up as this element this
being that exists out there
and it seems it seems weird that they
would do that and then not show us who
the person is
so either again we'll probably see who
the power broker is in like episode 5 or
episode six possibly
or they'll end up turning out that it's
actually sharon carter that she's the
power broker and the one that's kind of
been doing all this stuff right that she
was ousted from shields she had to find
a way to make ends meet and she
used her knowledge of shield information
and you know went to madrid started
selling her her information to the
highest bidder
because that's the best place to do it
and then one thing led to another and
there she was working with wilford nagle
synthesizing a super soldier serum right
like maybe that's just kind of what it
turned into
now finally to baron zemo byron zemo's
not going anywhere and my
my dire hope is that we actually get
like a stand-alone baron zumo tv show
where we get to watch him just dance
in a nightclub for an hour did you guys
see that video marvel released a
one-hour video of baron zemo dancing in
a nightclub and it's amazing it's
everything that i wanted it to be
it was amazing i think with baron zemo
he's not going anywhere and baron zuma's
gonna launch the thunderbolts i think
that's what's gonna come out of this
right that baron zemo is gonna go
forward and say okay like i think the
the whole story of his character is what
i've been saying it is in the sense that
he wants to get rid of superheroes well
what better way to get rid of
superheroes than to develop an
anti-superhero team of your own and then
destroy superheroes from within right so
i think that he's going to end up
going underground he's going to develop
the thunderbolts and i think that he's
going to ensnare carly morgenthau and i
think he's going to engineer us
agent u.s agent on i know on the surface
it seems like a hard sell
given everything that's going on but the
thing to understand is that historically
speaking in marvel comics when a person
ends up
basically losing their mind right when
their mind snaps they usually end up
switching from becoming a good guy to a
bad guy and i think that that
depending on how they choose to do it it
could be something as simple as the fact
that you know john walker
because of the fact that he killed you
know like literally killed somebody out
in public by beating them to death with
captain america shield that the federal
government
is going to cut him loose right i mean
at this point he's off reservation right
they're not really gonna tolerate that
and so i think they're gonna give him
the boot and i think in turn he's gonna
feel betrayed and he's gonna feel cast
off and abandoned and i think that baron
zemo is gonna swoop in and say hey
we can get back at them for what they
did to you and i think ultimately he'll
be like okay right he'll do it
grudgingly he'll do it as more of an
anti-hero but he'll do it nonetheless
i think for carly things are going to be
a lot simpler i think that he's going to
look at carly and say look what u.s
agent did to your your friends uh
u.s agent or why people with powers
don't need to exist out there we're
working with him because we have to
not really because we want to so put
your pride aside and like let's work
together i think that's a great way to
kind of introduce this notion of like
existing fracture before the team even
takes off pretty much guaranteeing its
end uh which is we all kind of predict
that's how it's gonna happen anyway
right if the thunderbolts were launched
you wouldn't see the team last forever
it would break apart somewhere along the
line
or it would allow for like a rotating
cast so like us agent or carly leaves
somebody else is brought in to take
their place or whatever it is
but uh i think carly would end up
joining the thunderbolts as well and i
think that baron zemo following that
over the course of the rest of the mcu
however long it takes is gonna travel
around to different people right he's
gonna travel around to different
locations and end up grabbing different
superheroes it could be one of these
things where because of the fact that if
we go with my theory that general
thunderbolt ross is the one who's
pulling the strings
and is the one who's like funding the
power broker possibly sharon carter that
he's got a vendetta against superheroes
right those who won't register and so
the thunderbolts end up becoming what
they were during civil war the original
civil war event where they tracked down
those individuals who have not
registered and so you end up having
basically this this kind of situation
where baron zemo is working you know off
the grid so to speak
with uh general thunderbolt ross in
order to track down superheroes and get
rid of them as opposed to somebody just
locking them up and kind of calling it a
day i don't know right i mean that's not
a fully fleshed out theory on my part so
it would take a little bit of thinking
but let me know what you guys think here
right like this idea
because i feel like i've got the ending
all sorted out right i feel like i've
got it all sorted out so uh anyway
anyway guys we're gonna bring this to an
end
thank you guys for watching and i will
catch you all later peace
you